[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
chaud
oui
[Musique]
je
2 moi
[Musique]
pas mal non ouais j'suis maquette
définitive non j'ai pas de site avec le
site soit +1 dire oui c'est simple vous
sur l'ordi et puis au début faut que ça
soit plus encore de 10,3
sa cause d'euros du fonds semble l'efs
jeunesse
blé goudé tranquillement mais c'est bien
bon super dit
et coûteux
moi je vais vous sauver gilles oui tu
vas me le mettre là en attendant les
et le seul le seul dj le seul dj bien
des lunettes font pâle figure passé le
disque
souvient de sa non cette musique me
souviens partie un tonnage maire de
saint quentin bryce
voilà
donc tu arrives pas non plus à
bombay laisse tomber un tuyau d'arrivée
non
alors non ouais
ça les gêne est à sa
4e étage canard
bon bah tu n'y es pas arriver un
donc je vois pas pourquoi pas non j'y
arrive pas normalement et en tant
qu'homme saxe et les mains sales ans
mais alors je vois passer ses dj
d'avancé ce choeur oui disquaires
tout vient bien voilà
souvient de sa grange
souvent contient 3 ou 1 7 6 et bien hâte
et superstitieux
[Musique]
on va voir ça va
julliard je passe un bon soir et demain
13 merci aux fêtes pour le dvd ah ouais
oui je veux tendre et est vrai mais je
joue dans son bébé dé tu sais c'est pas
vrai je voudrais semblait je suis dans
le sens des rides et ça sort bientôt là
non ouais j'en ai moi c'est toi you know
un temps chrono 30 ans chrono à wadi
abida ici julia soir je crois que c'est
très bien je crois que ça va très bien
pour toi tu vois tu te dis franchement
j'adore c'est le genre de décor pour toi
ouais alors le dvd ils sont bien tourner
nos meilleurs souvenirs ensemble et
beaucoup j'étais au tribunal à cause
d'eux
c'est sa date c'était quoi c'était à
l'époque je la trouve un car c'est la
clef pissed off tv ouais moi j'avais
publié leurs propos dans entrevue on
était au tribunal il était au tribunal
et où ils le jugent ils voulaient moi
j'étais de leur côté le juge voulait
absolument que j'y ai dit que je me
désolidarise de vous tue souvient de ce
jugement fort
carlos les carlos
[Musique]
alors ce soir assis toi ce soir ces
dîners caviar c'est sa carence un tour
dire et rien dire
qu'est ce tu vois ma chérie
je vais suivre
et moi y'a mon père il est aux brûlures
rapporte guerre dont est génial il me
suit partout dans l'appartement avec mon
vélo mais ce mois s'est tué par
ces gilets s'occupe de la pâte et
s'occupe de moi vachement bien oui sauf
pour mettre les disques mais pas très
doué
que tu as fait pendant la navarre fou
même à dix on finalement turin les gens
s'imaginent plein de trucs
1er janvier tu as fait une partouze
quand même
nom du tout 1er janvier très calme avec
quatre amis suicide et non 2 émis 6 1 et
un ami garçons et deux à nîmes et non ça
n'a pas fini en tarte
ce que tu as fait ta peau les fêtes
j'étais tranquille de noël en famille
donc et la mère qui est venue donc c'est
bien ça faisait longtemps que j'ai pas
vu moi mr ouai et puis jour de l'an
petite bouffe à la maison tranquille
disons que c'est vachement et marchi ton
truc la douleur de zhouqu ça m'a surpris
c'est toujours un projet télé projets
parallèles comme ça borderline comme ça
ça a du mal à prendre mais bon j'ai
trouvé une bonne équipe très bien
travailler j'avais des bons morceaux
derrière ça a pris congé
des dealers de rim avant un joueur de
rim il ya un morceau de ceillac et bien
malgré lui donc voilà 10 l'heure 2 zouk
l on prépare des heures de ragga
dancehall et c'est tout de même
satisfaits 1 h et comme avec le bisso na
bisso est un concept c'est vrai ça cette
dernière va bien
à bord avec moi
donc j'ai revu les liens avec l'afrique
pour tout ranger des constats ça me
permet
d'échapper un peu
allo ça ne vient pas à bout ouais
quatrième étage
4e
la censure
j'ai pas compris qu'ils étaient enfin
toute façon c
les doigts ça se passe ça va je trouve
que vraiment ça se passe bien
moi je suis partie en vacances avec mes
enfants parce que comme je les vois pas
trop non non tu vois comment avec le
boulot que j'ai je les vois pas trop où
ils habitent en normandie donc pour les
vacances à chaque fois c'est avec mes
enfants l'ont été aux maldives sur un
bateau pendant dix jours ensemble et
tout c'est important pour rattraper le
compère d'attaqué ils ont cessé mais
téléphone téléphone ça va bien mon vieux
port est ce que tu veux je commande des
buts
tu vois la photo j'espère
parce que moi le
le soir souvent quand je m'endors je me
dis [ __ ] j'aurais mon fils à côté
gérer l'embrasser tu vois là non parce
que béatrice ma femme elle vient pendant
la semaine mes enfants et je les vois
que le week-end tu vas donc y'a des fois
c'est dur
et déjà su sauf entente paris mômes sur
le dos il ya des gens tu aimerais bien
longs mois c'est un petit bisou serait
un jeune fille
[Musique]
quand ça va la star salut ça va donner
un jour c'est lui qui sait vous obtenez
les trois vous êtes looké comme c'était
possible
là c'est énorme
vous connaissez tu connais piccolino
piccoli juliette chesnel mais en face m6
jean gabin bonjour monsieur blaise le
connaître vu
la mousse karachi pas où il est
qu'est ce qui se passe
du bon temps pour tiendront je devais
venir devant petacchi d'un spectacle
qu'il reprend quand je reprends je n'ai
pas vu le prix je reprends je reprends
je réponds moi je peux les mains des
abominations si les noirs avant quand
j'étais noir avant quand c'est
[Musique]
extraordinaire et
le ceram âgé des frères qui te grand
talent d'acteur
mais sur le tournage est en effet
c'était quand on monte des noirs ça
m'intéresse avoir
fait jeu en fait je suis en vol
vachement la laine les thèmes se
s'étaient souhaite avec ce choix peut
faire le travail est un thème d'un bout
à l'autre ou prendre plein plein de
morceaux de j'ai préféré faire de la
diversité sting c'est
[Musique]
ouais je fais 17e sport encore une âme à
17 ans doit on aller les doigts tendus
les deux domiciles la pénombre
avec qui enfin turin ouais
ouais ils évoluent petit mais n'ont pas
voulu tuer beaucoup souviens pas quand
on était venus ici justement de faire en
bas il y avait sa copine qui a déchiré
des cas un très long temps de sa wii a
fallu longtemps pour lui d'arriver
en bas juste en bas dit et tu as croisé
stéphane et enfin parle avec lui et puis
moi je suis arrivé derrière j'ai dit
celui 1 c'est lui mais après mon à 100
mais ça m'étonne pas de
lui celui ci me stefan disch
celui joué c'est lui
on n'est pas devenu
johnny m'a tant apporté sur c'est lui
parce que je l'écris français michael la
groupe de lima tomber je comprends pas
ce que vous mêmes mais le pire qui m'est
arrivé c'était moins pire et le pire qui
m'est arrivé c'est joey starr devant
chez sonic vu ce qu'a voulu mekkaoui
vraiment me tuer moi et je suis parti en
je suis parti en courant j'ai vraiment
avec cette dent et où il voulait
vraiment monsieur et j'ai compris à
temps et je j'arrive au bout à place
d'un gramme et il ya un mec était là
dans sa caisse et où je dis je peux
monter dans votre voiture parce que le
mec il suit il veut me tuer je demande
le mec me dit oui je monte dans la
caisse et il a filé un coup de pompe
dans la portière de la bagnole il a fait
un truc profond comme ça le mec bon le
mec la bagnole il s'est barré et on
s'est arrêté cinq cents mètres plus loin
jeudi écoutez je suis désolé à cause de
moi monsieur les pour youtube si vous
voulez je vous paye quoi je vous donne
l'argent pour faire l'appareil elle
n'aime pas du tout non non il me dit
écoutez c'est pas je suis privé de biens
naturels mais ont été insultés on se
réconcilie
et qu'est ce que tu fais tu fais des
clips alors là j'ai fait j'ai deux
amants mon pays paris ah ouais bah ouais
qui aurait dû arriver théoriquement
pendant noël est bon il arrivera un peu
plus tard et je vais faire le troisième
l'a
au cv ou cb
original casse burnes non
pourquoi
bagard boisset s'emboîtent écoute moi
j'avance voir et du si l'arrivée il
arrivait dans le cinoche et à 36 berges
moi je suis arrivé dans l'est dans la
chanson en trente
et un parisien de badaboum des environs
moi c'est la même et puis il a fait
comme moi et là retapisser son blason
simplement quand j'ai vu voilà c'est
génial c'est qu'il a un côté quand le
ton années 50 y la façon dont
huit ans comme audiard tu vois il n'a
pas du tout entendu parler ouais c'est
toi c'est tonton flingueur quoi
ouais c'est mélodie en sous-sol eur65
mais tu t'appelles chars et le manque sa
tête charles
bassamat le jour où j'ai j'ai vu ça il
ya quoi 4 5 puis sur une vidéo j'étais
dans un vieux vidéothèque là et j'ai
regardé avant je regardais [ __ ]
charles ancien adjoint cherche à
remonter à ternir rejet du veto
hewitt est pas bête
[Musique]
il est où ce tome i un rival de renom
des états unis à temps j'avais dû aller
chanter avec beyoncé trois
parties dans une mini version
à une école de fois j'ai fait un très
bon mois lorsqu'elle physique
ça
ouais
quatrième étage
catherine louis 4e
quel âge comme ça moi ça
c'est vrai tu mets les femmes
falloir m'occupe du tour à tour
que jamais ce que les jeunes comme moi
le canton de
genève était alors ils étaient dans ce
cas unis là il est aux états unis donc
les stars des imbéciles investi sur lui
alors
j'ai fait
bonsoir bonsoir très heureux de vous
connaître
m
bon ça va bonsoir je connais pas nous je
crois qu'on s'est aperçu que tu es
habillée en même pas c'est même pas
habillé en toi même tu voulais poser
votre manteau
si tu ne t'oblige pas apte à billets ans
mohamed diame je suis pas esclave de mes
propres produits ouais
bon on va passer à table parce que la
cuisine et est bon et je vais chercher
[Musique]
vous vous connaissez tous la non
moins médias
tatiana
si
monsieur fassi
je viens ici
et personne n'a rien vu les gens ici du
tout à quoi tu te mets là charles oui
ici
c'est la
française vous êtes là
où c'est la toile bon je pars je pars
avec la princesse à à plus tard
super sympa de voir et
si vous voulez intune choix ne pas trop
de raisons de berre
déjà toyer et la joie de jouer
il a huit ans c'est la nama asselman
tiens toi daniel tu es là
mohamed fellah away mon fils gaston
c'est avait fait le même effet risqué
alors l'esprit les semis de sauver les
siens à l'abri les spirou il est tous
passés des grands clients cd conclure de
longtemps je viens de recevoir regarde
tous les soirs tous les soirs avant de
se coucher tous les soirs il m'envoie un
petit texte octroie à buenos de chess
eldad lost ou n'ose pas ce qu'on les
appelle les to sont ils sont en
normandie les pauvres
jeudi dépôt parce que c'est moi le
pauvre
tu sais quoi daniel moi je voulais pas
d'enfants jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans je
n'ai pas d'enfant et un jour je me suis
dit que c'était pire de ne pas en avoir
que d'en avoir fini
oui car j'en voulais vraiment pas moi
j'étais très anti enfants même d'entamer
ce qui t'a porte son nom alors voilà on
fait maintenant on met ces bons 48 ans
mais j'étais quand même à 43 48 91 ouais
ben dewar l'utilité ya rien d'autre ce
n'est rien d'autre
parce que c'est pour donner un coup de
bluff ou mixte aura dix pensent que les
fans ou pas c'est un autre bonhomme est
tu sais que nationale est une romanow
c'est vrai ça ce n'est rien non c'est
toi
qui s'intéressent à l'histoire votre
famille c'est la franche des romanov qui
c'est qui s'est réfugié en sibérie c'est
ça jean échappé au massacre bon ma
famille
c'est très compliqué en fait je suis en
train d'écrire un livre et c'était d'un
projet mais je suis née en sibérie et ça
vient des quatre intégrer la question je
voudrais vous poser s'il ya une une
vieille dame en russie là et qui est
morte ya peut-être cinq six ans où il
appartient way qui ont compensé que
c'était c'est vraiment une roumanoff ou
c'est une mythomane sarr il est allé au
plaisir n'y a pas que le sol et il n'y a
pas que réussit d'ailleurs plusieurs des
meilleurs plusieurs même aux états unis
est ce que c'était constater que etc ce
n'est pas vrai tu sais l'histoire des
pentes ou 19e siècle en france tu sais
que le fils de louis celle où dix nati
qui s'était échappé du tampon et pendant
tout le 19e siècle en france tu as eu ce
qu'on appelait défaut dauphin et a eu
des tas de mecs qui sont arrivés en
expliquant ils avaient la même
cicatrices que oui 17 où il y avait une
bonne femme qui s'était occupé des
enfants aversa et qui disait mais je le
reconnais c'est lui il ya eu plein de
gens ne commençait pas mind of qui se
connaissent mais qui et qui a d'ailleurs
on a été même avec les tests adn
maintenant ce serait vite lancé c'est
réglé pour lui ce qu on sait que non
mais il était reconnu lui-même au
luxembourg et touche une pension au
luxembourg comme il en a tant de
mystères et daniel en hollande à delft
avec sa tombe avec marc et bourbon et
nous toi tu as fait un bouquin au dessus
moi j'ai fait l'enfant léopard qui était
l'idée que marie antoinette avait eu un
enfant
adultérin noir puisque moi je travaille
sur la couleur parce que marie
antoinette avait quelque chose de
particulier sa première en essence quand
elle a mis au monde on a évacué la salle
ce qui se fait jamais mais à l'époque
les naissances royal c'était devant tout
le monde devant tout le monde il y avait
des mois dégâts grimper sur les sur les
armoires pour voir la maison pour voir
une nana oui parce que sinon pour
prouver bien sûr il faut voir la
naissance du roi sinon tu dis peut y
avoir une combine une
un trafic donc et maryvonne et encore
une fille ou un garçon
sa naissance on a évacué là on est avec
eux la chance je ris parce qu'elle est
en train de s'évanouir donc pendant
quelques instants on n'a pas vu la reine
à coucher et moi je vous suis si je puis
me permettre glisser dans sa peau
j'étais là et que on avait de quoi c'est
parce que le deuxième parce que le
deuxième le deuxième était en couleur et
donc on pouvait pas donc on a on a
éliminé ce gosse en a pas et vilain
petit canard voilà parce qu' il serait
le fils du chevalier de saint georges
qui a été maître de musique de marion de
marie antoinette ça c'est mon propos
romanesque à moi j'ai fait l'enfant
léopard et là je sens un deuxième roman
aujourd'hui demain qui raconte la suite
de l'histoire de l'enfant le par avec le
chevalier de saint georges j'aime pas ça
s'appelle la 13éme mort du chevalier qui
est cette histoire incroyable d'un
guadeloupéen qui a été le plus grand
musicien deux hommes sont envoyés
en toile est peut-être une [ __ ] ne
sais pas ce que tu attends je vais
raconter
non mais pendant sept ans ce louis saez
a pas pu être son mari parce que louis
saez il a été opéré d'un phimosis sept
ans après leur mariage vous dire que
pendant sept ans qui pouvaient pas être
le mari de marie antoinette
ils pouvaient pas même à comprendre ils
pouvaient pas maintenant la vérité c'est
que je ne peux pas encore des qualités
quoi voilà voilà je crois qu'on peut le
dire
ce que tout le monde salue montebourg
vachement de précaution avec julia
monsieur je pense que décalotter ça veut
dire
ça à était il n'a pas plu et donc il n'a
pas le septembre donc pendant sept ans
elle avait 16 ans 16 17 ans et c'était
une belle femme très belle femme moi je
suis tombée amoureuse n'a rien fait
quand j'ai appris qu'elle faisait 106 cm
de tour de poitrine
moi je connais deux ou trois petits
trucs pas grand chose mais je collecte
de trois petits trucs je sais que tout
ce que j'ai appris à l'école c'est que
du baratin
ça c'est clair la meilleure de toutes
ces jeanne d'arc attend jeanne d'arc
elle était illettré donc elle ne pouvait
pas parler un français de la haute thur
sujet d'hier puisque c'était une
paysanne ou encore pire que as donc
maintenant du jour au lendemain elle se
retrouve à parler anglais imagine toi à
parler anglais alors qu'elle n'avait pas
parlé français désigne déjà un problème
tant j'ai dit à la vente et achat à
monter à cheval en plus et de plus on
était dans les années où une greluche
n'avait pas vraiment grand chose à dire
en ce temps là j'avais vraiment rien à
dire restoy je te culbute c'est tout
bête toi je t'ai culbute voilà et du
jour au lendemain il a une armée
il a une vision d'histoire de france qui
je traduis
napoléon là où il était fort je pensais
c'était quoi servent de défense innée
cas des as mais jamais battu les carrés
musulmans
première petit bout de chou gras trans
corp la latte mais t'es pas sérieux
voilà voilà un nom et ton magasin à new
york alors il va être fini fin janvier a
tant fait un magasin à l'union n'ont
jamais dans le sens de new york en plus
nous voir changer et moi tu fais une
ligne avec wikijob
le magasin
quel genre de vêtements de se faire je
pense soit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'eau
ah ouais là
[Musique]
c'est pas
beau la vie
[Musique]
bonjour
comment ça va et dis moi comment ils
vont te vois
[Musique]
tu dois laisser moi mais dès que je les
connaissais depuis longtemps connaissait
jean gabin dans les première soirée rap
où on allait les plus âgés que moi et
c'est donc il connaît plus mes grands
frères et il a beaucoup traîné chez vers
chez nous là donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
des affinités amoureuses depuis
longtemps des liens de sarcelles quoi
donc un peu plus jeune que moi même je
n'étais ni ambitieux ah ouais oui il
voulait sortir son nez voilà ce que j'ai
le marché jusque là dessus elle avait
même pas un vol puis le mend avait
annoncé que
tous que la même fille joy à cacher je
prend la fuite
non il d'abord il était livreur dans une
pizzeria catch cacher tu as à sarcelles
un coup de champagne
devenu patron de la pizzeria et un jour
ça je sais pas si tu te souviens de
cette histoire un jour à sarcelles et
anne sinclair depuis le téléphone huawei
strauss kahn 1 la soirée que strauss
kahn et anne sinclair a téléphoné alors
son brouillon et dépend dépêchez vous
les pizzas pourquoi ça vient pas il
était avec strauss kahn qui est député
député du val et
forêt donc et donc tapé anne sinclair
qui gueulait livres et moi ni vraiment
les pizzas livrées mois les pizzas et
bon finalement lui avec un vin pitt à
faire d'un seul coup c'est quand même
beaucoup quoi il arrive avec les pizzas
et mais pas de but et attendent bien et
ils m'ont payé un an et demi at il un
pays
moi je n'imaginais même pas anne
sinclair et strauss kahn devant une
pizza
les
caisses et dit moi aussi strauss-kahn
maman moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
interpellé chez moi mais de la première
fois je les ai vus dans quand ils
vendent et ses freins de marché
au déballage
c'est ceci en axant ouais ça bien drôle
d'accent c'est à dire même pas vraiment
dit avec moi ils amèneront de l'accent
et parle comme ça c'est à dire monsieur
voulait vendre allez venez venez
ses prix de
revient sur scène mondiale cité où il
est noir les rebeus grandi en même entre
eux mais nous a grandi avec des feuilles
mélange
et ses associés après avec les frères
kalfon donc si tu veux la vérité tout ça
vise à cacher à société frère caché
c'était le matin non c'est mohamed il
habite à arlington et c'est l'endroit où
kennedy est enterré non
j'imagine le mec était bien lui alors ma
bouteille à moi médias et kennedy quand
même assez bien
six agresseurs en virginie sallé takako
trouve à xinjiang ont dit que washington
en virginie virgin vient 500 ans en
arrière je te jure tapas de beacon
[Rires]
offrira le coton et le vent
ça c'est bon
tu sais ce qu'il a commis là une une
cadillac 4,4 nom
de casey
m'enquérir toute excuse mais ce
qu'affirmait raison des mclaren mercedes
alors
pour les beaux appartements
oui mais le métro quand on ne sait pas
très bien ce n'est même pas que ça
existait pour saluer les porsche 4
calmer les cas difficiles et risquées
les routes comment s'appelle ce voile
important ça consomme beaucoup moins la
sacoche à
la naissance et pas chez paul rodet de
laquelle les quatre 4 1 dans sa peine
depuis peu ils ont planché le mal tout
le monde est
bien digne à 4-4 pika tu as vu un
endroit cardiaque effort parce que
mohamed il est même arrivé à embrouiller
tapis non ouais j'ai rencontré tapiwa
c'est mon histoire il avait bien envoyé
au tapis lors le jeu m'a plu c'est parce
que je voyais ma revue un grand service
dans l'histoire c'est que j'étais au
martinez ouais et à l'époque je voulais
me faire connaître voulait faire
connaître ma marque on va dire et jeté
avec un sac de t-shirts où je voulais
faire une grosse émission donc avec
certaines personnes qui reconnaissent à
cette fois qui est passé dans l'émission
capital etc et je vois bien un tapis en
bas et il reconnaît mon pote parce que
mon pote il était là qu'entrent effet un
morceau que j'ai
donc y mettons pas je le connais celui
qui fait des vêtements devra commencer à
parler puis web bannières faut qu'on
doit il faut qu'on en parle c'est
écoutez si vous voulez rejoindre mois au
bar donc mon pote thomas broberg ou
entre temps je vais dans la voiture je
ramène à sec de votre moi je veux je
vais en mars moi j'étais gonflé je
m'assois j'ai bon voilà c'est pour tes
enfance pour ceux ci c'est pour ta femme
permettre l'émission allait bien tout va
commencer à parler tous les coups si tu
as quelque chose de potable passe me
voir dans ma chambre ma chambre c'est la
chambre tentant tanger ok je suis au
parti dans sa chambre on a parlé pendant
deux heures m après l'histoire de noël
des trucs enfin des choses qui sont
restées privées nature
[Musique]
la
caméra qu'on
va traiter en coupe bonhomme
autres et ce qu'on
aime le football donc après ce que j'ai
fait c'est que je suis parti dans ma
chambre j'ai rené jeudi j'étais dans ma
voiture je fais croire que je veux noté
alors qu'à l'époque je te remets dans
une voiture avec un pote à moi ce
n'était pas une cadillac à l'époque non
non c'était une voiture de location qui
était louée par matisse le web il
dormait dans une voiture de location de
m'adresser romanaise pas pu le ramener
un polo le polo été froissé donc j'ai
donné 200 franchement après ça m'a fait
mal au coeur mais bon j'étais obligé à
une dame pour qu'elle repasse bien
souvent deux sens et la cdc au martinez
et ils ont repassé le polo tout gérable
en sachant et alors et il m'a dit ok je
vais faire pour toi mais j'espère que
t'as pas appelé tous les médias de
france comprendra photo parce que moi il
m'a dit qu'il avait une image il avait
dit l'ex marteau j'écoute mois l'ex
myboto
il a fait quoi avec ce pôle et il a mis
il est descendu non pas pour faire des
missions pour l'émission je suis triste
manière et ça se voit un polo noir nous
allons également bien viendra s'est bien
passé c'est bien face et du mois après
j'ai le csl rien vu
c'est surtout la main
la main droite était jeune et allah est
alors à partir de ce moment ça va partir
de ce moment à partir de mars qui a été
bien c'est que au moment où la marque
était identifié banlieue et quand darth
hâter la porte s'est produit c'était
plus bon qu'à monsieur tout le monde qui
dit babou cissé bon
après on va dire ça plus démocratisé moi
mon produit mali
ce qui est assez mais maintenant il fait
même les cahiers pour les écoliers
parfois je fais des téléphones et tu
prends 5 pour maintenant ce sont les
sponsors en plus royaliste que ça mais
ça en vaut mieux prendre 5%
209,1 me dis que j'ai fait dans le
décret de france inconstant et tout ce
qui concerne les licences et d'autres
business différent mais je suis un homme
décédé sur steam conflit dont ses
messagers c'est la soirée de l'étrange
comptent en leur sein
oui avec moi je m'appelle
tantaoui j'en suis chez conti
à retirer comme une rebelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as fait pour ce qu'est
ce que tu viens madame non
marabout
[Musique]
regarder transpire revenir c'est
peut-être parce que
je
vois là ok on s'appelle comment
[Musique]
la question fut l'ami kane
non faut pas penser
comme ça que
je mange un peu de jambes et aux bras
diouf et mohammedia ambassadeurs de la
culture et de la jeunesse emploi ou vous
avez jamais battu en charge excellence
et ce qui est génial tu vas avoir un
passeport diplomatique alors
[Applaudissements]
raymond
n'est ce pas que
j'allais voir le num mais ces attentats
le président ferait sérieuses et le
président sénégalais qui vous a dénoncé
le président sénégalais comme a
rencontré n'était pas sénégalais moi
j'habite dans le jeu la chaussée mais
gaulois mais
je sais mais
c'est pas maliens joie bien sûr les
parents chômeurs manitou s'attend
maintenant daniel
comment il est quand il est ce qu il dit
j'ai dit à moustey sénégalais oui je
suis régalé chez les gaulois m'enfin bon
et luigi sénégal et du mali ses parents
sont du maniement assez grave reste mari
il a un passeport c'est extraordinaire
non
faveur du sénégal
reste alors à savoir
expliquer comment dois je dire
on va nous expliquer comment on est bien
grand père est légal et il arrive à être
des africains seront que je dis la
vérité tous des africains
chrétiens les maliens et tuer le malade
a ici
mes parents ils ont des monteurs la
famille de perrine du sénégal ils ont
immigré comme alou diarra non sénégalais
à la base mon père est né au mali ma
mère elle est né au mali la mère de ma
mère ma grand mère et sénégalaises et
les diffuseurs au sénégal c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui quand je viens chez toi
aujourd'hui quand je viens j'y arrive
parfois je m'appelle mois médias
sénégalais mais moi je devais tout doux
moi je dis je suis nominé jeudi je suis
le mariage parce que mes parents sont
nés au mali bon sinon
c'est qu'elles sont en parler d'eux je
pense moi la bonne
film de michael youn va nous en
dessinant vous vous lavez tourner vous
là c'est quoi le onzième commandement
quoi ouais on est parti à moscou en
russie ouais on est pour le seul de
trucs cool parce qu'il voulait aller en
apesanteur c est donc le seul endroit où
tu peux le faire en france ils ont
refusé dès qu'ils ont dit michael youn
et mais qu'ils ont dit on va pas te
laisser dans l'avion voilà donc le seul
endroit où tu fais un ou tu fais un
chèque et ils peuvent aller c'est dans
un avion parabolique c'est là bas que
j'ai visité la cité du cosmos et ça et
pour apparaître en apesanteur l'avion
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent faire alors ils
montent à 3000 m d'altitude et coupe les
moteurs ouais et pendant 25 secondes
donc il n'y a plus de moteur l'avion il
descend comme ça et ça crée la pesanteur
pendant 25 secondes et remet les moteurs
donc tu d'études montrent déjà tu prends
des jets c'est le poids ton poids x 4 et
après quand ça descend donc tu montes en
impesanteur et redémarre le truc et tu
retombes par terre mais ça veut dire tu
le fais quatre fois donc ça tout le
monde a vomi et tout le monde est avec
des facs les mecs et pourtant ça vient
tu fais un vol en hélico et et je te dis
bon il son retour de l'avion tout le
monde parle sur les evil avait filmé on
a tout fait mais c'était un film c'est
le turini ouais c'est vraiment grave un
vrai départ et que ses pattes et ils
sont
disons les gens et les gens qui
s'attendent à abyei au cas ce qui n'est
pas le cas du tout moi je dirais que
c'est plus du monty python et ben voilà
c'est plus du monty python c'est un fait
il ya l'histoire voilà il ya une
histoire qui donne enfin il ya une
histoire on a pris prétexte d'une
histoire pour faire des trucs de dingue
jeudi on a été au stade gerland on est
parti là-bas déguisé en groupe genre les
web du web donc il ya quarante mille
personnes ou trente huit mille personnes
dans un match dans le match auxerre lyon
donc on doit on est en face de la
tribune des bad gones supporters extrême
de lyon franchement face d'eux et donc
si on rentre et on filme y avait des
mecs qui étaient dedans personne n'était
au courant donc on arrive genre pendant
la mi-temps et ils disent voilà un jeune
groupe les ouates du web qui vient nous
chanter une chanson et tout est donc un
derby c'est le pire des derbies dans le
foot c'est lyon saint-etienne c'est
ouais c'est encore pire que
des tests et donc les mecs qui ne
calcule pas tu vois des mecs en train de
manger comme ça et tout d'un coup ils
disent et voici un jeune groupe leweb
double nana donc l'on arrive de
saint-etienne là tu vois mais genre 38
mille personnes se lever et hué était au
milieu du stade et tu prends un souffle
comme ça et on arrive et on commence à
capella et on chante le lion est mort ce
soir s'il peut arriver mais qu'il
devienne loi c'est quand même des trucs
comme ça c'est que des paris
c'est des commandements qu'on a
analysées on les a interprétées à mirta
roses y intégrer on a écrit on était
plusieurs à michael enfin l'équipe sur
la toile à moi j'avais écrit la beuze
c'est moi qui avais eu l'idée de base du
film
j'avais écrit donc on a rampé c'est une
grande idée
mais ce que génial dans ce film c'est
que c'est un film qu'en programmant
contre monfils contrairement aux films
habituel huang il ya un scénario qui est
écrit la sq un film qui crée des
événements dont on sait pas ce qui va se
passer certainement disons que c'est un
ovni dans d'endroits qui a été fait dans
time en français par un film si c'est un
film c'est ça c'est ça qui est bien
c'est qu'on m'explique dedans on a fait
des performances vrai et vous avez tous
tourné là c'est fini ça sort bientôt
l'année onzième commandement la mairie
de molières falloir et la single aussi
michaël youn qui arrive quand même
les larmes d'efforts michaël youn c'est
quand il a fait alphonse brawn ça se met
bien aller quand il fait comme des
connards ça sonne bien mais se prend la
tête
disons que c'est un mec perfectionniste
daniel je te raconterai le corps quand
j'ai fait un casting n'a point fort je
n'avais pas débuté dans le métier j'ai
fait un casting je suis allé à un
casting de publicité donc j'arrive là là
là là je crois qu'il l'a casting se fait
impasse le story board jeudi storyboard
arrive à presles m'explique un petit
voilà c'est une publicité pour gérard
pasquier tu vas tu m'as dit voilà c'est
un aventurier donc qui qui avec cette
femme zhang un peu indiana jones --une
une femme james bond girl vachement bien
en habillant parce qu'ils aient tous les
regards sont à l'aventuré qui coupent
qui découpent à ma chaise ou qu'avance
le monde est une bande d'agités
d'indigènes qui arrive qui les emmène au
village ou fhf un chef tâche et du
village qui arrivent et qui baragouine
quelque chose
nous
dit voilà ça c'est ce temps libre on
leur a fait preuve et donc moi que moi
c'est pas ça le dresser nos trucs ces
gens comme ça je dis mais c'est
vachement bien plus tard
on est un black pour faire lol pour
faire le l'aventurier avec la bonne
femme c'est super vous vous innovait
c'est super c'est pour l'indigène
s'est arrêté vers m'envoyer dans les
allées les oiseaux le ciel est amer en
80 chez pas combien c'est taghmaoui mon
poteau 50 envoyé là bas il m'a envoyé là
bas je vais là-bas est comme moi j'étais
moi même j'avais dix kilos en plus donc
j'arrive en marcel hills en plein été
julien échauffement table je fais là bas
j'y arrive et on me dit est ce que vous
pouvez parler comme un gus de city usa
j'avais comme ça je dis moi j'habite pas
dans une cité mois après me dit non mais
voilà tu vois tu vois les yeux visites
jardin des jeunes cette piste
puis je me vois pas moi fergus de 17
piges après je suis même dit bon on va
vous trouver un autre hall a
déjà regardé me dit vous faites quoi
comme sport et les bras j'ai commencé à
regarder si je fais du
tennis de table elle me dit alors on a
un rôle pour vous vous vous mettez là et
vous bougez pas à le poteau de praslin
le poteau ton problème à toi en plus de
besoins de daniel c'est que tout le
monde te procure
les 48 carteron martiniquais et mais il
m'arrive souvent d'avoir des gars qui
parlent en arabe je ne peux pas leur
répondre mais prennent pour un
peu le fassiez
sa soeur maëlys et connaissent marconnet
souvent quoi tu vois commissaire à toi
moi j'ai des projets au commissariat et
donc à temps mais bien sûr ça a été
visée alors qu'ils ne sont pas prises au
sérieux les quatre heures tu sors allez
c'est bon groupe
thormann un commissariat toi ouais moi
j'adore ça on m'appelle nomades ou
mamadou je dirais tu m'appelles charles
badou j'ai dit tu continues à appeler
mon badge est appelée martinez sanchez
convalescent et brett fait plus de télé
devise d'athéna est-ce que parce que
j'arrêtais mcm ce que je faisais hip hop
cherel qui est vrai plus d'un an qui
marche très très bien malheureusement is
it il ya plein de facteurs qui font que
quand tu es une femme que tu viens du
porno et que tu es en pousse blacks ça
fait 3 répond c'est pas raison de ta
doré pour moi
oui mais pour moi pour moi aussi ces
trois cas l'histoire
je suis parti
mais oui sur mcm non parce que c'est une
chaîne avec qui j'ai travaillé en 95 qui
m'a donné ma chance en 95 qui m'a
toujours donné ma chance quand je suis
allé les voir mais malheureusement être
en quarts des chaînes il ya toujours un
problème non mais tu vois on est en
cours nous sommes le plus rim pluta
nisme américain poucet quand on dit
allez les blacks ouais les blacks l'a
fait du porno et 23e alors que
bizarrement je serai beaucoup moi je me
changeais une femme méchante femme mais
je travaille beaucoup et asie aux
etats-unis j'ai aucun problème est
qu'avec ces trois choses la
gérante a plu et j'ai dit je vais te
dire c'est le seul pays où ils te parle
de l'intégration toute la journée et que
s'il fait tout ça marche le moigne a
c'est à dire que l'intégration il faut
arrêter de parler de l'intégration parce
que c'est vrai que la france à intégrer
des italiens des espagnols et des
polonais avant la guerre mais depuis on
a pu intégrer personnes il faut arrêter
de dire aux gens de l'intégration ça ne
marche pas ça n'existe pas c'est un voeu
pieux mais c'est des [ __ ] tous les
aline les animateurs lacroix fondée
casting sur fun tv frère tu vois
toujours des bruns yeux vers vous et
maintenant tu as vu quand tout cas les
sites comme la laine et les gars ont
droit les loire c'est ian cook où les
mecs qui comme moi tu vois vite fait et
cours
ils ont dit on va voir toutes les
minorités les jeunes conclut noir ou
trois occasions en france en angleterre
c'est ya pas deux il ya personne à la
télé il ya lancé et alors c'est quand
même le pays du monde où on t'explique
toute la journée l'intégration
républicaine les américains ils en
parlent pas d'intégration des anglais
non plus et ici te prenne la tête toute
la journée avec ce alors qu'il faut une
loi le sial toi tu es un exemple
peut-être d'un mec qui s'en est sorti
par la culture est pas mais c'est rare
franchement je ne sais pas comment sera
la fin à la fois c'est rare et en même
temps en même temps ils sont en train de
le payer parce que mettons prenant
quelque chose on n'a pas fait de folies
mais le ps le ps il s'est planté
pourquoi tu regardes l'équipe de
hollande s'est pas l'équipe du pays bas
tu vois pas un black c'est à dire que
dans dans l'équipe des dirigeants tu
vois pas de gare représentant le pays
auxquelles s'était chacun dans l'équipe
de france n'a que des blacks et à
l'assemblée nationale temps n'a pas
serré je vais te raconter un scoop sur
les élections sur les élections je te
raconter un scoop moi j'étais au comité
de soutien de jose pas d'accord bonds
est bon mais je suis allé voir jospin
même un débat j'ai dit bon j'ai vu le
j'ai vu sa prestation j'ai dit bon j'ai
dit on a perdu dans la semaine qui a
précédé les élections des gens bien
placer mon téléphone et ils m'ont dit
d'ailleurs on a les sondages des
renseignements généraux ça va pas il
faut que tu interviens jeu attendez les
gars attendait maintenant que ça va mal
vous voulez que des mecs entier comme
moi il y en a d'autres interviennent
avant où ils étaient où ils sont et ça
c'est extrêmement grave c'est est
sidérant je dis attendez vous vous
rappelez maintenant et avant qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous avez fait et
maintenant vous êtes inquiet parce
qu'effectivement il savait avant on
savait avec les sondages des
renseignements généraux qu'il allait
être en dessous de l'open c'était la
panique intégral c'est l'âge et à vous
j'ai dit non j'ai dit non
attention qui va là où vous aurez double
ac qui cherche c'est qu'ils bossent pas
mal faut pas regarder à l'intérieur
la princesse du bien
alors je déconne à ces menaces et autres
faits
c'est un vrai nom était tout seul est
stoppé tout
ponctué choisi son roi et tu vas être
marché bah oui bien jardiner c'est
possible
qui a trouvé la fève voilà les bonnes
c'est cette galette
mais n'est
pas très belle qui des trois maintenant
un qui va tomber comme moi la famille
c'est entre peuls 1
c'est mon côté mon côté du mali saint
gilles de ce qu'est une couronne pour
lui
il faudrait tout à coup la
baisse que les peuls c'est vraiment
aussi c'est quelque chose de particulier
oui c'est très particulier ce sont des
matches on est vraiment à
l'origine c'est pas des commerçants
des bergers se sont déclarés plutôt
marrant c'est que nos
marchés c'est possible tout commençait
comment il se sentait bien sûr
[Musique]
j'en peux plus le disque a relâché pas
de moi
[Musique]
ça me fout en commun
mais nous savons la pousse à fond là
[Musique]
yannis
mallat k
ok à l'arrivée
le bar
l'attentât
à
tangi l'égyptien blanc et gilles canton
et disquaire je suis un blanc mais
morges est et disquaire quand il y avait
un blancs démarrent oui j'étais bien
on
josias et finit bien mais si tu portes
un canari lier mon côté
le voisin d'où tu sors mon voisin du
dessus
qu'est ce cas qu'est-ce qu'a l'antimoine
cache cache qu'est ce qui sera dit moi
c'est non mais ça c'est juste du gabon
le monde fait il a un peu de mal à avoir
mis un
taquet la jaked un chemin
alors qu'est ce que tu attends à votre
fils est décédé
gérard est donnée pastilles extrait de
son extrait de son nouvel album chasser
zoom voilà
les connards sensu il a ajouté peut
garder pour ma fille parce que là j'ai
un produit incontournable il ya la
campine mohammedia le cd mohammad le ce
n'est pas si les coolies acheter là
c'est comment ça va car on va te donne
et m6 ont été données si je reviens pas
ouais je vais te faire
[Musique]
18 sur 20
laisse tomber daniel béthouart
[Musique]
comment on le sait
j'essaie je rajoute au fini
tu peux déplacer le problème moi je fais
tous les jours
voilà ici tu fais des signatures là pour
ça mais elle est magnifique sa mère mais
pourquoi n'est pas
seulement je sais
elle me met dans la machine et
innovation
c'est mohamed d'habitude pêches melons
qui s'amène atteint il ya trop de bla
qui ce soir là
quatre préfectures et les blacks qui
sait
c'est le sieur 1100 rue avec une heure
d'avancé oui vote des chiens préférés
vous offre ce petit cd bon anniversaire
l'anniversaire
ouais
le maire
évidemment mon beauf les beatles passe
les gens c'est normal et affligé toiture
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu